AGE W
CAN BE .
HERE'S CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJAY GUPTAI
INRMTO ADDRESS YOU
AGENDA.THE ALGORITHMSND
OF MILLIONS
SAW NFORMAN SOCIAL-OLD JIM SELL
MEDIA AS WELL ASEB RESULT, THEO.
HIGH SURRA. 100 PEOPLE THAT COV
AFFECTS, THE VAST MAJO
AYD TAKE AN
OU THINK
SURVIVAL RATE IS?
>> WHAT THEY P 98.5 TO 99.
>> THAT MEANS 0 PELE DIE.
ARN T
A NEARLY 4
MIPEOPLE WILL DIE.
S 97% ARE THE BIG DEAL?ABD DEA.
TWO DAYS LATKINGY
THAT I GO TOTHE HOSPITAL AND GEA
E ME TO TH
HOSPITAL.
TH.
>> I DIDN'T GET ANY SLEE
NG ABOLOT OF P
ANOU TRIED TLL THE
HOSPITE EMERGENCY ROOM,
YOU WOULD ASK WHERE HE IS.ER
WORKING ON HIM.
I WOULDN'T HAVE ANY ION.
ER ABOUT TEN DAYS HE HAD
TYPICALR
COVID A. HAD A COUGHND
BREATH.
HE
>> Reporter: THIS MAN IS ACTWN
PATIENTS
UNDUHIHOUT THE PANDEMIC, LIKE
HET,R TAL ORGANS ON A CELLULAR
LEVEL, IT TOOKS OXYGEN TO GEM TI
MONITOR MASK O
A M BE
ITATED.
I'M IN SHOCK.SAID, T KN CAN
O ALL WE CAN
>> RteSPEND TIMEU WHATVIS
INTOR EXPLAININGWHAT ELY HAPPEN?
T
X-
THE PULL MONARY DOCTOR SAT'PPE .
AS WE MOVE DOWN TO THE MIDDLE
AND LOWER  RIGHTUNG,
YOU SEE DIFFUSE ANT  PNEUMONIAER
FLAN MTI.THE TISSUE AIFN >> IT'A
ITS THE REST
>> Reporte 1 OF ALHOSPITALIZED
DAMAGE. NKEIM, OLTRCAMPBELL WAS
OVERWHHEUR VIRGINIA
LIVED, COVID JUSTDIDNEEURGENT.
NOTHING MAKEr: WIFE AND
TWO OF HISIDCOME SIC
THTHEY GOT
KEEPINS MISE
K.
.WI TART O
THG THAT.
IT'SN YOUR OXYGES.USE YOU N' ST
>> Rep ANALYSIS OF UDIES FOUND
20% TO 30% OF ALLL
T  THAT  WILLOP BLIKE TRAVIS DI.
PROBABLY MORE OF A VCUSEPIRATORT
T
TRAVISSTLED WITH HIS OWN
REALIZATION THAT THENCESI COME
E  G
DAUG WEDDING IS
TER THAN WALKI
AS
SPED FOR6 DAYSND
NEARLY 1S LATER, HIS TRYING TO
I'M 40% R TWMONTHS
WHAT I LACK IS
STAMINA.DORENUOUS,ILL SEND MYGRW
THE TRUTH AND CONSEQUENCES OF
ALKING NG VACCINATED.
ABOUT THIS.
ISG TO A
INTERACONGOING TO LE >> I
R ALMOST DIE AN
YOU ARE SI FRIENDSR THIS?EA  TR.
LIRLY E 20 ATAGSE COVID-19, HE
SYMPTOMS, AT LEAST TWO MONTHS
AFTER HI
>>S
EVERY DAY. FTF, HEADACHES, S OG
BREATHE.
IT'S BEEN ONE THIN
OTE WE IO SPITAL
PART OF AT 80%F
>> COULD HPREVENTEOF THIP AT YO
LOCAL PHARMA, E  F
JAJOUSHAS  YET.HE WILIT MONDAY.
WE CHECKED IN WITHIM.
IT'SEETOPI LIVESPEOPLE WON HIM
GEED. WILDOT HIS
BOOSTER WHEN HIS TIME IS DO.
OUNDES.HOW IS THE MEDICAL INDUSY
COVID, MAYBE HOSPITALS
TO THIS.
TALKINGENOPLE DEALING WITH ERE'